[Musik]
wissen Sie eigentlich wie viele
Flüchtlinge schon in ötten in
Deutschland leben 3 Millionen
Flüchtlinge das heißt jeder dritte bis
vierte unter 1000 ist ein Flüchtling der
hier lebt in Deutschland ich hasse nicht
zu sehr wie den blöden Saga von das Boot
ist voll das Boot ist nicht voll aber es
ist in stürmischer See und wir müssen
aufpassen dass wir nicht sinken wir
können das nicht so hinnehmen auf die
Dauer denn wir können nicht auf unsere
demokratische Gesellschaft verzichten
und die kommt in Gefahr wenn wir
überborden woher kommt das das kommt
daher weil Putin der Kriegsmeister
uns damit erpresst indem er überall dort
wo der bombardiert weiß er dort geht
Flüchtlinge und die werden dann am
besten nach Deutschland geschickt das
war in Syrien so das ist jetzt in der
Ukraine so und so speit sich langsam ein
ganzer Berg von drei Millionen
Flüchtlingen und es werden mehr und mehr
von Tag zu Tag auf das kann so
weitergehen das kann auf die Dauer auch
nicht gut gehen das heißt aber was
können wir tun und da gibt es nur eine
Möglichkeit Waffen liefern damit der
ganze Wahnsinn permanent weitergeht das
ist nicht die einzige Lösung wir müssen
schauen dass wir Frieden schaffen auf
jedem Art und Möglichkeit schauen dass
wir die Friedensbewegung oder
Friedensverhandlungen dort möglich
machen das ist die einzige Möglichkeit
dass es wirklich auch für uns zu
ertragen geht nicht nur das was sie
sagen dass die Energiepreis und die
ganze Politik und die ganze Wirtschaft
wieder funktioniert sondern dass wir
diese Flüchtlingsproblematik auch in den
Griff bekommen okay das finde ich sehr
spannend Frieden schaffen mit Putin das
ist ja nur eigentlich das was im Grunde
genommen alle irgendwie wollen man will
Frieden für die Ukraine aber Frieden mit
Putin wie kann man sich das vorstellen
mit ihm reden wie soll das funktionieren
ich glaube es gibt ein gutes Beispiel
das auch so zum selenskischen genannt
worden ist Österreich war nach dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg so wie auch
Deutschland von vier Mächten besetzt und
hat mit den Russen damals durchgesetzt
durch selbst deklarierte
Unabhängigkeit durch die selbst
dekorierte Neutralität das ist ein
unabhängiger Staat geworden ist das war
auch nicht so leicht und nicht so
einfach weil wir waren damals genau wie
heute Ukraine an der Grenze zwischen den
beiden Systemen und das ist nicht nur
gut gegangen sondern das kann durchaus
auch für die Ukraine eine Möglichkeit
sein ich sage nur einen Satz noch dazu
dann gleich kommt gleich der Kollege
Gaffron wenn er schaut so böse aus und
will was ganz anderes sagen
ich kann mich auch auf jemanden der
vielleicht nicht das links Seins und so
weiter verdächtig ist auf Henry
Kiesinger
hat gesagt Henry Kissinger hat gesagt
und zwar schon vor zehn Jahren die
Ukraine
it's a perfect Buffer state hat wir
brauchen unbedingt in der NATO wir
brauchen Sie interessieren
und zwischen Russland und der NATO Tipps
geben wäre das auch also ihre Taktik
also dass wir einfach über andere Völker
hier das ukrainische hier am Tisch
einfach urteilen als sei dass eine
Schachfigur wenn sie nicht parieren
gehen Sie in die russische Knechtschaft
oder bleiben Moral was auch immer die
Ukraine ist ein souveräner in der
Vereinten Nationen
Mitglied es ist garantiert worden
1998 in den Vereinbarungen und 2008 dass
die Ukraine souverän ist dass sie einen
Schutz genießt und so weiter also haben
sie aber auch neutraler Start machen die
Russen haben ein schweres
Völkerrechtsverbrechen begangen hier
besteht ganz eindeutige Klarheit und ich
kann ihnen eins sagen
die Franzosen haben gesagt
1900 und 39 als Hitler Polen eigentlich
Vergleiche Hitler mit Putin um das da zu
sagen denn in dem Moment als die Nazis
Polen angegriffen haben gab es einen
Beistandspakt zwischen der franz
Frankreich und Polen dann hieß es in
Paris für Danzig sterben nein acht
Monate später marschierte Hitler durch
den Triumphbogen in Paris das ist die
Antwort
durch totalitäre Mächte und deren Logik
und der ist nicht mit kuschen weil sie
sagen mit putinen kann man nicht reden
gehören zwei der will ja nicht mal aufs
Tanzfläche gehen jedes Gespräch ab wie
stellen Sie sich denn eine
Friedenslösung vor wir müssen dem Russen
zeigen dass Völkerrecht existiert
sie Vereinigten Staaten Österreich
übrigens seine salonrolle da tanzeln an
der Seite konnten sie nur von dem
Hintergrund der NATO und der starken
Bundesrepublik das ist doch eine Salon
Diva Nummer die sie abziehen frei sein
Land das nur von dem festen Garantie des
westlichen Bündnisses existieren kann
und diese schaukelrolle eingenommen hat
schneidet sie sind sie sind Russland
mit der Mentalität würden sie das auch
so unterstreichen würden Sie sagen ja
nee mit putigen kann man nicht reden
oder kann man doch ich bin keine Russin
ich bin mit fünf Jahren nach Deutschland
gekommen weil wir Deutsche sind ich
kenne die Mentalität der Russen
eigentlich nur aus der persönlichen
Sicht das sind ganz freundlicher und
sehr herzliche sehr sehr emotionale
Leute was da politisch geschieht da
steige ich nicht so durch ich bin kein
geopolitiker was ich aber in in all den
Jahren für mich persönlich immer
propagandiert habe ist abrüsten abrüsten
abrüsten was mich sehr stört und ich
weiß ihr werdet es über mich herfallen
ist dass Deutschland mittlerweile ich
glaube der fünftgrößte rüstungsexporteur
ist und Rüstungsexporte Waffen erzeugen
in Krisen Flüchtlinge und das ist
einfach eine Tatsache
darf ich darf ich auch dazu sagen dass
Flüchtlinge
der Krieg in der Ukraine schon etwas
länger geht als dieser wirklich
schreckliche aber ein Fall der geht
schon seit 2014 da gab es das Massaker
Notdienst gehen sie mit mit
erpresst jetzt Flüchtling ich glaube
dass das Putin eigentlich überhaupt
nicht darum geht ich glaube das ganz
andere Sorgen gerade das empfinden wir
so aber das haben wir damals auch
empfunden als es in Syrien so war ich
glaube wir müssen aufhören Waffen zu
liefern Ihnen alle möglichen Gebiete ich
glaube wir müssen aufhören mit Krieg
Geld zu machen ich glaube wir sollten
mal auf Artikel 20 das zivilpakt 1
gucken wir dürfen nicht in Krieg
investieren am ihr im Artikel 1
Grundgesetz Absatz 2 steht drin wir
sollten dem Frieden der Welt hin ich
glaube wir müssten eine Friedenspolitik
machen wir müssen Verhandlungen führen
wir müssen dafür sorgen als eine sehr
mit beiden Parteien wir müssen die dazu
kriegen dass die miteinander sprechen
miteinander sprechen das ist das was
viele Jahrzehnte lang viele Politiker
gemacht haben zufrieden
durch lächerlich ist das wirklich eine
friedensrolle die ja da treibt ich habe
ja das Gefühl dass Erdogan eher nur für
sich selber seine eigenen Interessen
durchsetzen vielleicht einmal
europäische Interessen durchsetzen
möchten
die anderen und weniger um uns selbst
also bei diesem Thema fällt es mir
schwer etwas zu sagen weil ich auch sehr
schwanke ich ich höre ihnen plausibel
ich höre ihnen zu ist plausibel was ich
ziemlich dann immer ein bisschen zurück
auf meinen auf meinen Max Weber der ihm
gesagt hat bedenke das Ende also eben
Verantwortungsethik und dass man halt
schaut vielleicht
dass man zu sehr hier außerhalb des
Kriegs mit einer Art gratis Mut etwas
fordert und vielleicht überdenkt oder
übersieht dass letztendlich die
Bevölkerung dort ist ausbaden muss aber
ich bin da wirklich kein Experte ich
weiß dass meine Patienten die teilweise
auch aus dem Donbass kommen das sehr
unterschiedlich sehen ich was berichten
ich das sollten Sie selber sagen weil
ich möchte das auch jetzt gar nicht ich
weil ich bin nicht gefestigt in dieser
Meinung ich kann jetzt nicht sagen die
haben teilweise eine andere Sichtweise
wie zum Beispiel die Medien hier ich
kann aber nicht beurteilen ob sie an der
Propaganda unterliegen wahrscheinlich
ich weiß alle miteinander ich weiß nur
das ist differenzierter oft gesehen wird
und das einzige wo ich jetzt vielleicht
hier beitragen könnte ist noch mal der
Appell dass man nicht die Position
vertritt was fühlt sich jetzt richtig an
sondern dass man wirklich auch bedenkt
was kommt raus
ganz kurze Frage nochmal zum Thema
Flüchtlinge zu denen die auch kommen und
die hier sind aus der Ukraine könnte
nicht vielleicht auch eine Chance sein
in Zeiten von Fachkräftemangel wenn man
jetzt zum Beispiel auch sieht wir haben
großen Ärztemangel auf dem Land
Pflegekräfte ähnliches kann das nicht
vielleicht auch eine Chance für uns sein
also ich glaube dass wir die Leute die
wir brauchen im Moment nicht bekommen
zum Beispiel aus der Ukraine das soll
aber nicht negativ sein ich habe ein
großes Herz für Flüchtlinge wir müssen
nur auch ab und zu mal an uns selber
denken also und jeder und was mir
meisten zu nerven geht ist ob das jetzt
der Ministerpräsident Kretschmer ist der
sagt also Friedensverhandlungen und in
dem Moment wo man Friedensverhandlungen
nur den Mund nimmt ist man schon ein
Putin Freund nein das sind sich gut im
Freien das sind Menschen
auf Verantwortung das ist eine große
Kontroverse Verantwortung geht nicht ja
natürlich Ethik schon gelernt
Nachrüstung ja es ist so Helmut Schmidt
wurde natürlich
lange in die Geschichte gehen Ich will
noch Folgendes sagen wir müssen ein
bisschen differenzieren es gibt
Kriegsflüchtlinge und es gibt Asylanten
Kriegsflüchtlinge die unter Bedrohungen
sind müssen aufgenommen werden das ist
eine fester Status in uno Dokumenten
festgelegt und den menschenrechts-
Topf mit Gas beschossen werden von den
Russen im übrigen oder ob sie aus der
Ukraine kommen können sie nicht abweisen
das ist Punkt eins dass ich hier nicht
alle europäischen Länder so verhalten
wie man es erwarten könnte ist eine
andere Frage Österreich beispielsweise
ist vorbildlich in der Aufnahme von
Flüchtlingen danke sehr aber genau
die einzige Möglichkeit die
Flüchtlingsproblematik zu beenden ist
Frieden zu finden
und das zweite ist wenn man so viel in
neurophil power reinlegen würde wie das
Nachrüsten auch in das überlegen wie man
vielleicht Friedensverhandlungen führen
könnte und was dazu
stehen russische Truppen vergewaltigen
Frauen plündern und ziehen barbarisch
durch die Gegend das können Sie
natürlich bestreiten behandeln
wenn man und jetzt folgendes ich habe
bei mir zu Hause Leute aus der Ukraine
aufgenommen ja ich habe ein Haus Vorbild
das möglich noch nicht vorbildlich das
sage ich Ihnen deshalb ich mache ganz
andere Sachen auch nicht die auch
vorbildlich sein könnten aber
zwei Kinder sieben und elf Jahre 11
Jahre geht in die Schule ging relativ
schnell in die Schule der bringt bereits
jetzt dem Lehrer wir haben es nicht
glauben
it bei der beherrscht besser den
Computer als der Lehrer und seine
Mitschüler wir sollten mal nicht so
hochnäsig sein hier am besten und sagen
wir wir hängen nämlich aus der Ukraine
kommen wer wissbegierige sehr
interessierte junge Leute verstanden sie
haben Ukraine Flüchtlinge bei sich auf
ja eine Familie Frau mit zwei Kindern
okay wohnt bei mir seit Monaten so und
das bedeutet dann mache ich gar kein
Ding da ist okay es ist alright weil ich
selber Frischling Mal war ich weiß es
ist Zeit aber die Situation ist hier
gleichzusetzen mit irgendwelchen die
muss ich sehr vorsichtig sein dass ich
gegen hier nicht gegen korrekten ist
verstoße mit jungen Männern die sagen
wir mal aus Nordafrika kommen und
zwischen 25 und 35 sind gut gebaut und
sind noch nicht hungrig aus die dann
hier nach einem Jahr Asyl abgelehntem
Antrag Duldung bekommen und dennoch kein
sozusagen keine Anstalten machen sich zu
in da sehe ich eben schon ein
Unterschied zu denjenigen die aus der
Ukraine zu uns kommen zwei Drittel sind
Frauen zwischen 25 mit kleinen Kindern
alle kommen irgendwann mal in unser
Gesundheitssystem wenn ich ganz kurz mal
unter eingreifen kann und da bin ich
nämlich kurz vorbei Herrn Frank wieder
haben Sie das Gefühl dass unser
Gesundheitssystem das ja nun durch
Corona und ähnliches eh schon ziemlich
angeschlagen ist durch den
Fachkräftemangel den Pflegekräfte Mangel
und ähnlichem die ganze Abwanderung
glauben sie dass wir das dann noch
stemmen können dass wir jetzt zusätzlich
noch Millionen Flüchtlinge auch noch mit
in unser Gesundheitssystem integrieren
jetzt machen sie ein ganz großes Fass
auf Gesundheitssystem ist
ein Haifischbecken das hat ist es mit so
vielen Interessen überlagert und wenn
wir das Gesundheitssystem mal in Ordnung
bringen könnten dann wäre das auch kein
Problem
entsprechende Kriegsflüchtlinge
ordentlich zu versorgen das wäre
überhaupt kein Problem wir haben
Gesundheitsprobleme eher das Problem ich
will es gar auch über Corona sprechen
dass wir eine völlige Vergeltung von
Ressourcen haben dass wir eine
übertherapien haben dass wir tatsächlich
viel zu viel Intensivbetten zum Beispiel
haben dass wir viel zu viel ja wir haben
zu viele insofern
alle das sagen alle die wirklich nicht
krank sind zwischen ambulant und
stationär also die wirklichen Fachleute
ja wir haben es liegen es kommt
komplette es kommen komplett die
falschen Leute wir haben zum Beispiel
wer liegt denn zum Beispiel auf
intensivabteilungen oft das sind
Menschen die kommen aus Altersheim weil
man dort aus Personalmangel und
Ressourcenmangel quasi mit mehr Pflege
nicht zurechtkommt und dann werden die
teilweise intensiv versorgt was wiederum
hervorragend abzurechnen ist ich sage
Ihnen ganz böses Wort wir sind teilweise
die cashcause im Krankenhaus also wir
haben strukturelle Riesenprobleme sind
einfach teurer die kann man besser
abrechnen und deshalb wir haben doppelt
wir haben doppelt so viel weiß ich nicht
genau die Zahlen ich habe doppelt so
viel wie die Schweiz und dreimal so viel
wie ich war aber wir haben die wirklich
mit Abstand wir haben ja auch deutlich
und Bürger als die Schweiz also
im Verhältnis also wir sind da ganz in
der also wir haben das ist ein ganz da
müssen wir jetzt eine eigene Sendung
drüber machen aber an den Flüchtlingen
liegt es nicht wenn unser System
überlastet ist